kevin i'm going to throw this one to you
to start here so i was reading that you
wrote the screenplay on spec and nick
knew nothing about it so it was making
me wonder did you have any backup plan
whatsoever was there any way to pivot if
nic cage was not interested in making
this movie
no not really um and you know tom and i
wrote it together so
uh
you know i think there were moments when
once we had written it and we were
trying to you know get the project going
there were times when i think personally
i would kind of
be selfishly because i wanted to make
money and sell the script somewhere we'd
go ah maybe you know this actor or that
actor but you know
end of the day no nobody else could
could have done it just for fun because
now i'm curious like let's say you had
to cast someone as nic cage who would it
be
cast someone as nick
oh as nick as the cage i have no idea
nick has said he's like i think uh if
gene wilder were alive he would have
played that great idea to play me i
don't know who could do
nicholas
cage christian bale or daniel day lewis
in full prosthetics probably yeah yeah
okay
i mean i'm glad the movie is the way it
is but i would buy that
yeah maybe daniel day lewis yeah those
guys could do anything all right tom now
i cannot get over the fact that this is
your second time directing a feature
film it really does blow my mind i know
this and that awkward moment are two
completely different types of movies but
were there any specific lessons learned
on that that made you think if that
movie did not come first and i didn't
have that experience i would never be
able to pull off this in massive talent
well you know i'll say this i think that
the the real thing that made this movie
possible is my collaboration with kevin
because that was a new thing that we
developed on a television show
and uh we were doing this thing where we
were seeing writing things and and and
shooting them and editing them and
putting them on the air so quickly and
we did it so many times together that it
was really that collaboration and sort
of honing the voice that we had on the
page and then you know our collaboration
on set and in the editing room that's
like the lessons like
the lesson i think for us was have
someone else there that cares as much
about the project as you do and you it
really helps you get through it
i think that's like the most important
lesson anyone can learn in this industry
yeah yeah
yeah it's a it's always a tough process
but it's like part of it is just
you know keeping going and keep trying
to make it better
and for me as a director yeah it was a
big challenge i'd never done a lot of
the things that are in this film before
and it was it was important to just keep
an eye on like the tone and and keep
moving forward i feel like there's a lot
of things you do in this film that no
one's ever done before and that's part
of what makes it so special i mean it i
really do i'm gonna force you guys to
get creative again here let's say you
get the opportunity to turn uh massive
talent into an anthology series can you
pick another actor to play themselves
and tell me what genre their movie would
be in
another actor to play themselves well we
did i'll tell you we did have a
conversation with nick about doing the
reverse where it's just nikki okay and
then nick shows up three times and we
thought that would be a very funny idea
but in terms of other actors you know
we're not really sure because like there
needs to be a couple things they need to
have like a career that has highs and
lows and there needs to be like a ground
swell behind them where for some reason
people just want nicolas cage to succeed
right they just want him to be okay sort
of like he's transcended the idea of
being an actor and he's become like a
cultural institution he's a meme star
he's a movie star he's all of these
different things and there aren't that
many other people that have that kind of
very specific background so
i'm not i'm not totally super we're
dodging it or dodging i have a pitch for
you i want one with jamie lee curtis and
it needs to be a horror comedy
i would watch it
you're hired
i'm totally down any time you guys want
we will talk
again thank you so much for your time
and
congratulations on this movie thank you
so much